oh the new Tom Cruise movie edge of
tomorrow is about time travel well no
wait that's not quite right either the
new Nicolas Cage movie edge of tomorrow
is about a man stuck in it analyst Lee
we're eating pine whoo I said Nicolas
Cage howdy the new Tom Cruise movie edge
of tomorrow is a total ripoff of
Groundhog Day the new Tom Cruise flick
edge of tomorrow is the best movie about
video games ever made even though it
isn't about video games cruise plays a
clumsy noob of a soldier killed in
battle with hideous aliens but then he
somehow wakes up right before the battle
dies again and wakes up before the
battle again it keeps happening and he
gradually gets more and more adept at
combat lasting longer and longer it's
based on a Japanese sci-fi novel by a
former engineer and a hardcore gamer and
the movie does a better job of capturing
the experience of playing a game then
all of these adaptations put together
you see most movies about video games
present the protagonist the character
the player controls as an unstoppable
killing machine
but if killing bad guys was really that
effortless it would mean that the game
was lousy if a game is actually
challenging then you will die when you
play it you will die a lot edge of
tomorrow unfolds like a well-designed
game a game that makes you tackle
obstacles over and over again holding
your technique memorizing patterns and
learning by trial and error most movie
adaptions of games ignore that and focus
all their energy on recreating the story
that's crazy the story is the least
important part you see there are two
schools of thought about what
constitutes the fundamental element of a
game on one side or the narratology who
are of the opinion
and those are just a few of the titles
that you should peruse if you want to
read more about it hey did you just get
my fascinating lecture on video game
theory like it's some kind of bad
cutscene well I guess we'll just have to
start over then won't we
one moment of your life would you most
like to go back and retry don't say
hitting play on this video let me know
in the comments and subscribe to the
wired Channel